You’d probably never notice a tiny
jumping spider in your living room,
but it’d surely notice you.
While the arachnids are famous
for their excellent vision
and vibration detection,
new research shows that despite
their lack of ear drums,
they can also hear sounds.
Researchers discovered this
by putting tiny electrodes
in the sound-sensitive parts
of the spiders’ brains
and placing them on a metal box
that cancelled out
vibrations from below.
Then they played a sound at the
same frequency as the buzz of a wasp
that preys upon jumping spiders.
Not only did the spiders
freeze and look around
just as they’d do when
startled in the wild,
but data from the electrode
showed brain activity
spiked in the auditory area, too.
This shows they actually hear sounds,
from a wasp dive-bombing
to you crunching a potato chip.